nationaliste
encore une fois le premier le premier
test d'abord et avant tout de quelqu'un
qui est capable de prendre les reins
d'une partie et amener ce parti à une
victoire c'est le test du leadership qui
vient du Saguenay de Québec de Montréal
peu importe c'est quelqu'un qui est
capable de prendre ce parti qui
présentement comme l'on dit mes
collègues et pris en otage par sa
députation du Westland et de faire en
sorte que ce parti devienne le parti du
Québec et non pas le parti du West
Island moi je vais vous lancer un autre
nom si c'est étant donné qu'on est on
est on est à la poursuite de chef puis
on a regardé le Scrum de de Monsieur
Diane Charest malgré le fait qu'il est
jeune c'est pas une mauvaise chose
d'être jeune
l'ADN l'ADN est évidente était capable
de maîtriser sa façon de répondre aux
journalistes
probablement qu'il n'ira pas
puis Michel vous savez là-dessus
beaucoup plus pour moi mais c'est ce
style de caractère que le parti a besoin
ce style de personnalité qui n'a peur de
rien qui est capable de se retrousser
les manches comme son père l'a fait en
1998 quand est arrivé d'Ottawa puis il
savait à peine où sont les toilettes à
l'Assemblée nationale et bien sûr 5 ans
plus tard il était premier ministre du
Québec Jean cheri d'ailleurs de son fils
qu'il a probable peut-être plus de flair
que lui politique c'est déjà quelque
chose mais la question était posée à
Monsieur Diane Charret Dimitri puis il a
dit non non non non je suis pas rendu là
j'ai encore trop petit
expérience Michel maintenant c'est sûr
qu'Antoine j'ai aucun doute qu'Antoine
fera de la politique un jour mais pas
maintenant si Monsieur marchand a pas de
d'expérience de leadership comme dit
Dimitri Antoine en a encore moins mais
je suis convaincu qu'il va rester
impliqué avec les libéraux encore de
très nombreuses années et qu'un jour il
fera de la politique
pas beaucoup de doutes là-dessus
effectivement il y a on peut se poser la
question est-ce que ça va jouer contre
les libéraux de faire une course à
lâcher prise plus tard et ça vouloir un
sauveur moi je crois pas beaucoup dans
les sauvages mais il est évident dans
mon esprit que ça prend une personnalité
qui a cette expérience de leadership
mais qui a cette connaissance du Québec
une connaissance approfondi et qui est
capable de créer le lien avec la
population québécoise et qui a une bonne
compréhension puis que un sens politique
développé et en ce moment si les
libéraux ne vont pas vers cette course à
la chefferie c'est parce que ils ont pas
cette personne là même avec ceux qui
sont dans la députation actuelle
Martin gay mon chef des ragies Frédéric
moi ce que je sens et j'entends c'est
que
au fond on le dira pas publiquement on
le dira pas ouvertement mais ça figure
pas on pense pas que parmi les noms que
vous venez de mentionner il pourrait y
avoir quelqu'un de suffisamment
convaincant pour devenir chef et ramener
le parti là où il devait devrait être
dans dans les composantes qu'on a
mentionné tout à l'heure alors il y a
tant en espérant que peut-être le
document du groupe de travail présidé
par André Prad pour ressusciter de
l'intérêt mais honnêtement oui mais ça
sera pas non plus suffisant ça prend
quelqu'un qui
veut faire de la politique qui veut
devenir peut-être Premier ministre pas
en 2026 mais qui sur un moyen terme plus
long terme crois qu'il faut qu'au Québec
hier encore un Parti libéral du Québec
faut y croire faut y croire
et et dans ce sens là cette personne-là
elle ne sait pas encore manifesté et
est-ce que moi je lance pas la serviette
là je suis pas du tout au contraire mais
c'est évident que plus on attend plus ce
sera difficile pour 20-26 pour 2026 et
là faudrait pas se retrouver avec un
parti qui carrément risquerait de
disparaître alors il y a une stratégie à
développer d'ici cette commission
mais attention avec la personne qui peut
nous amener et et et et raffermir
l'identité de ce parti libérale ah ben
oui voilà et c'est ça la difficulté pour
pour eux en ce moment parce que dans le
scénario plus tard que tôt il y a des
gens qui disent plus tard en 2025 ça
permet à des gens qui ont actuellement
un emploi puis qui peuvent pas s'en
libérer de se présenter
en prévision des élections 2026 et
Françoise vous voyez ça comme
c'est sûr que le défi est énorme et je
pense que le Parti libéral du Québec a
besoin d'un vrai leader quelqu'un qui
est prêt à être le chef de ce parti pour
dire ce que tout le monde veut entendre
mais qui est capable d'arriver avec une
vision du caractère est capable de
rassembler tout ce beau monde autour de
lui les turcotes comme les les personnes
avec des noms plus anglophones dire
qu'il a ou elle a une vision parce que
on le sait tous la politique ça change
tellement rapidement qu'est-ce qui nous
dit puis quoi venez moi je suis pas
d'accord je pense pas il y en a
peut-être qui retarde leur décision
parce qu'ils disent ah je veux pas être
le prochain chef qui va encore planter
en 20-26 mais il devrait arriver comme
Jean Chauray qui est pas pris le pouvoir
en utilisant pourtant il était il était
le héros qui arrivait d'Ottawa qui
venait
mais il faut que tu penses que tu vas
même le PQ doit penser qu'il va prendre
le pouvoir du haut de ces trois sièges
présentement
de penser que le Parti libéral du Québec
doit se dire à juste pour un petit bière
ici
au contraire allez-y avec tout ce que
vous avez vous le savez François Legault
change d'idées comme il change de
chemise à chaque semaine jouer là dessus
c'est pas possible
mais c'est pas en pensant à petit qu'on
va devenir grand pensez plutôt que la
CAQ c'est peut-être un espèce de petit
je sais pas moi une erreur s'est
produite pendant x nombre de temps on le
connaissait pas vraiment ce parti-là il
est un peu moribond pendant un bout de
temps réellement
on connaissait personne d'autre alors de
ce contexte là il y a rien qui dit que
François Legault va être encore capable
de tenir son parti à bout de bras c'est
sûr qu'on en connaît un petit peu plus
que François Legault maintenant alors
c'est parti libéral est prêt à payer le
prix puis travailler fort moi je vois
pas pourquoi ils peuvent pas s'essayer
puis quelqu'un qui va me montrer qu'il a
du courage politique de prendre des
règles maintenant pas tant que quelqu'un
d'autre se casse la gueule maintenant là
les choses sont prêtes pour moi ça
marche pas de même pas un scénario
d'Hollywood c'est quelqu'un qui doit
aimer les défis parce que
c'est clair ça quand tu es chef de
partie Sébastien tu aimes les défis
Jean-François
la stratégie de musique Anglade elle
souhaitait si tout allait très bien elle
souhaitait prendre le pouvoir en 2022
mais elle avait une stratégie de rester
pour 2026 c'est comme pas simple après
abondance avait très bien que ce serait
un miracle qui gagne en 2022 donc lui
était dans une stratégie plus longue
c'est pour ça que j'avais dit ici qu'on
retrouverait ces deux personnes là au
débat des chefs en 2026 alors je me suis
trompé mais c'était ça la stratégie de
Dominique Anglade mais la défaite était
tellement dur et les gens étaient
tellement mécontents à l'interne qu'elle
a décidé de partir le problème de
gestion du caucus aussi bon alors c'est
peut-être une situation particulière
mais c'est sûr que pour la prochaine
fois
la question du moment dépend absolument
de la personne si j'avais la bonne
personne tout de suite et qu'elle était
prête à le diriger tout de suite tout le
monde dirait hey on fait on fait la
course immédiatement parce qu'on a la
bonne personne et là on va attendre que
la bonne personne se présente
le problème avec ça c'est que parfois
bon Justin Trudeau comme le dit Dimitri
c'est quand même extraordinaire parce
que il avait Laura de son père c'est
quelqu'un qui n'avait aucune expérience
de leadership il y avait été ministre de
rien il y avait jamais géré quoi que ce
soit même pas le chiffre du soir au
Burger King dans papino je veux dire et
c'était carrément arrêter de dire ce que
je pense
arrêter de dire ce que je pense avec
quoi
et il a quand même surpris il y avait
une aura le problème avec Monsieur
charrette et moi aussi j'ai trouvé je me
suis dit
très bon dans son point de presse le
problème c'est que le nom Charret il est
très populaire au sein du Parti libéral
mais il n'attire pas des votes à
l'extérieur du parti alors il a pas
Laura de Monsieur de Monsieur Trudeau de
son nom de famille quoi qu'il en aurait
il y a des gens qui qui arrivent au
pouvoir et qui se révèle je peux vous
dire que Lucien Bouchard était un très
très mauvais orateur il y a failli
perdre son élection comme conservateur
la première fois et il s'est révélé dans
le rôle un bon orateur et c'était
c'était quelque chose d'acquis ça veut
dire que quelqu'un quand je vais prendre
André Fortin qui depuis qu'il est là
dans l'opposition je trouve qu'il fait
des bonnes interventions il travaille il
traverse pas mais on dit bah si devenait
premier s'il devenait chef on le
découvrirait autrement alors il y a des
gens dans notre histoire politique mais
ça c'est à qui on ne prévoyait pas une
belle carrière mais qui se sont révélés
dans dans le rôle et d'apprendre
d'apprendre que Lucien Bouchard était un
piètre orateur ça nous renverse un peu
parce qu'il est il était une catastrophe
sa campagne électorale est en train de
se faire battre pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI